[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
انه
المتسببين في انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
بالمحاسبه ويقول انا لا احد فوق القانون
الخلافات تتسع بين قاده طالبان افغانستان
زعيم الحركه يضغط لاقاله رئيس الاستخبارات
وجناح حقاني يتصدى
ازمه نفوذ بالمحيطين الهندي والهادئ
تتفاقم صفقه غواصات نوويه مرتقبه لكم
لجنه امميه تحمل الامم المتحده والنظام
السوري مسؤوليه تاخر وصول المساعدات
لمنكوبي الزلزال المدمر
مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من التطورات
المتلاحقه لازمه انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
وسطى مخاوف داخل الولايات المتحده وخارج
طبعا الولايات المتحده من حدوث ازمه
مصرفيه في جميع انحاء العالم
وفي اول خطاب له بعد الازمه توعد الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن بمحاسبه المتسببين
بانهيار بنك سيليكون فالي قال ان لا احد
فوق القانون مؤكدا ان النظام المصرفي
الامريكي امن
ابتدائي
اليوم وجهت الاداره بالتحرك سريعا لاحتواء
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي بامكان
المودعين الوصول الى اموالهم بدون عوائق
المستثمرون الذين يخاطرون بودائع
الامريكيين ستتم محاسبتهم ولن تكون هناك
حمايه لاصحاب قرارات المخاطر التي ادت
لهذه الازمه ولن نسمح بتكرار اخفاقات
البنوك وسنعمل على حمايه الشركات الناشئه
اريد التاكيد على ان دافعي الضرائب لن
يتحملوا اي خسائر بسبب ازمه البنوك
طبعا يبدو ان تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون
فالي بدات في الظهور وذلك تباعا افتتحت
الاسهم الامريكيه على تراجع واحد بالمئه
وذلك في اول جلسه لها بعد انهيار
البنكريما هوى سهم الامريكي بحوالي 67%
عند الافتتاح تراجع مؤشر داود جونز للاسهم
الامريكيه 0.6 في مطلع افتتاح وول ستريت
اليوم الاثنين
هدفي الولايات المتحده في بريطانيا ومع
تصاعد المخاوف من امتداد تاثير ازمه بنك
سيليكون فالي على شركات التكنولوجيا
البريطانيه اعلن مصرف اتش اس بي سي انه
استحوذ على الوحده البريطانيه للبنك وقد
اتمت حكومه سوناك صفقه البيع في استجابه
سريعه طبعا لتجنب تداعيات الازمه قال وزير
الخزانه البريطاني قال ان الحكومه
البريطانيه وايضا البنك المركزي سهل عمليه
البيع عن شدد على ان الودائع ستكون محميه
ولكن دون اي دعم من اموال دافعيه الضرائب
حيث جدد التاكيد على ان هذه الودائع ستدفع
لاصحابها دون خطه انقاذ تشمل اموال دافعيه
الضرائب هناك كان قد قال انه يتفهم قلق
عملاء البنك ومخاوفهم مؤكدا انه يعمل على
مدى الايام السابقه وايضا خلال رحلته من
لندن مع وزير ماليته وبنك انجلترا وايضا
الجهات التنظيميه على ايجاد الحل الامثل
لقد واجهنا وضعا كان بامكاننا فيه رؤيه
بعض اهم شركاتنا الاكثر استراتيجيه تمحى
وكان من الممكن ان يكون ذلك خطيرا للغايه
لقد بنينا على مدى العقد الماضي ثالث اكبر
اقتصاد تكنولوجيا في العالم بعد الصين
والولايات المتحده لذلك من المهم جدا لنا
كدوله ان يزدهر هذا القطاع ويجب ان نتاكد
من ان يكون لدينا حل
لكننا كنا نبحث في جميع الخيارات وكنا
بحاجه الى التاكد من انه اذا لم يحدث
البيع فلدينا حلول اخرى جاهزه ولهذا السبب
كان من المهم القيام بقدر كبير من العمل
على مجموعه متنوعه من الحلول خلال عطله
نهايه الاسبوع
على كل المزيد مشاهدينا من التفاصيل حول
الازمه وتداعيات هذه الازمه ننتقل مباشره
لزميل
الله راح تفضلي شكرا ميسون
اذا مشاهدينا تراجعات حاده نراها بالاسواق
العالميه اليوم سوق الامريكيه افتتحت
اليوم في اول جلسه لها بعد ان سيطرت
السلطات
الامريكيه على ثلاثه بنوك كانت منهاره
اتحدث هنا عن سيليكون فالي عن وايضا
ورغم اعلان السلطات بانه كل الودائع سوف
تكون محميه لانه سابقا تامين هو فقط على
الودائع يلي قيمتها 250 الف دولار ومادون
القرار صدر بالامس انه كل الودائع بهذه
البنوك المتعثره سوف تكون محميه وتعاد الى
اصحابها ولكن الخسائر سوف يتحملها مساهمو
البنوك وايضا الدائنين بالرغم من هذه
الاجراءات التي تم الاعلان عنها قبل
افتتاح الاسواق الا انه اليوم عم نشوف
تراجعات حاده باسواق الاسهم الامريكيه
خاصه اسهم ولكن يجب ان نفرق بين البنوك
الكبرى والبنوك الصغرى لماذا لانه نحن
بنعرف بعض الازمه الماليه العالميه البنوك
كان وضع قانون دوت فرانك اللي بينظم اداء
البنوك
بحد من قدره البنوك على اخذ المخاطر ثم في
العام 2018 على ايام الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب كان في لوبينغ من البنوك
الاصغر انه يجب تخفيف هذه الشروط الموضوعه
لهذه البنوك الاصغر لانها مكلفه ولا يجب
ان تعامل كل البنوك
بالمثل بالتالي تم تخفيف القيود على هذه
البنوك من ضمن موضوع الستريس اللي بتقوم
البنوك فيه لذلك ظهرت هذه المشكله يلي لن
تكون موجوده بالبنوك الاكبر اما نشوف
اليوم تراجعات على البنوك الكبرى تراجعات
مقبوله ولكن كيف نقارن ذلك مع البنوك
الاصغر لحاتم مثال هو بنك شبيه البنوك
التي تعثرت اليوم سهم ومتراجع ب 67% وتم
وقفه عن التداول رغم انه قبل افتتاح
الاسواق قال انه امن 70 مليار دولار
تسهيلات من الفيدرالي وايضا من بنك اليوم
تشارلز شواب ايضا متراجع ب 23% بنسبه
قياسيه
على هذا المصرف التالي المصارف الاصغر رغم
اخذ هذه الاجراءات عم نشوف منا خروج للاسم
وحتى استمرار لخروج الاموال من هذه
المصارف والذهاب نحو المصارف الاكبر هذا
فيما يتعلق باسهم البنوك الامريكيه عوائد
السندات في اتجاهات نحو الملذات الامنه من
هي الملادات الامنه السندات بالتالي عم
ترتفع اسعارها بشكل كبير ونظرا للعلاقه
العكسيه العكسيه بين اسعار السندات وبين
عوائدها عم نشوف تراجعات قويه على عوائد
السندات سندات السنتين اليوم وصل الى مدون
الاربعه في المئه اليوم يعود الى فوق هذه
المستويات باخر ثلاث جلسات اكبر خسائر
منشوفها على عوائل سندات السنتين منذ
الاثنين الاسود منذ العام 1987 عائد العشر
سنوات ايضا متراجع بخمسه.6 كانت التراجعات
اكبر من ذلك هلا عم نشوف تقليص بعض الشيء
لخسائر على عوائد السندات وعائد سندات
الخمس سنوات عم بيسجل التراجع اليوم 8.3%
نفس الصوره عم بنشوفها بالاسواق الاوروبيه
تراجعات قويه على
الاسهم المصرفيه الاوروبيه التراجعات قويه
على عوائد السندات الاوروبيه اليوم عائد
السندات الالمانيه تقريبا عم بيسجل
التراجع بمستوى قياسي ها هي اسهم البنوك
فيها خسائر قويه ولاحظوا عوائد سندات
الخزانه البريطانيه التراجعات القويه
وخاصه عوائد سندات قصيره الاجل لانه في
تساؤلات فعلا هل هذا سوف يؤثر على قدره
البنوك برفع اسعار الفائده والمضي قدما
بالسياسه التشدديه واليوم ننتظر اجتماع
اساسي ومهم جدا استثنائي من الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي على كل المشاهدين نستكمل الحديث
حول هذا الموضوع مع ضيفي الان ينضم الي
عبر الهاتف مجد دوله مدير استثمارات
الاسهم في بنك ابوظبي الاول مجد اهلا
وسهلا بك هل ترى بانه هذه التراجعات
الحاده التي نراها على اسهم البنوك
الامريكيه والاوروبيه هي تراجعات مبرره
وماذا تتوقع اليوم من اجتماع الفيدرالي
الاستثنائي
بالتراجعات اللي شهدناها يعني هي من يوم
الجمعه
مع نهايه يوم الخميس بلش
نا تراجعات حاده على الاسهم الاوروبيه
خصوصا
على البنوك الاوروبيه يعني هو هو موضوع
ذعر يعني بشكل يعم الاسواق يعني في
تراجعات حاده حتى على شركات اوروبيه ليس
لها علاقه
المالي ومثل ما ذكرتي
يعني هاي اسمها
العالم عم تتجه نحو المنازات الامنه
السياديه للدول الاوروبيه وعم نشوف عمليات
تخارج من الريسكي يعني الاصول
[موسيقى]
تطلب المخاطره مثل الاسهم ومثل العملات
المشفره والى اخره يعني الكثير من
المساهمين او المستثمرين بالوقت الحالي
هاي الحادثه عمله مثل يعني رياده تشيك
لتؤثر الوضع الحالي الاقتصادي اللي وصل له
اقتصاد الامريكي والاقتصاد العالمي بعد
سنه كامله تقريبا فينا نقول من بدايه
التشديد الكمي وبدايه ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده هلا هذا الشيء اللي عم بيصير هو
نبيل شوب احنا ما بنعتقد هذا الشيء احنا
بنعتقد انه هاي حاله معينه يعني هي نتيجه
استثمارات معينه صارت بالبنك ولم يتم مثلا
اخذ الحيطه والحذر بشكل مناسب وتم عمليه
دخارة مليار يعني هل هذا الشيء معناتها
انه والله
ما ممكن واحنا سمعنا كمان الرئيس الامريكي
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني اكدوا انه ودائع
الاشخاص الافراد والشركات بامان ولكن
المساهمين هم راح يتحملوا خسائر وهذا اللي
سببها بالتخارج الكبير يعني
الخسائر وتفاقمت التراجعات على المنتشرات
الامريكيه مع ظهور الرئيس الامريكي
وحديثه عن التجديد على الرقابه مره اخرى
وحديثه على انه المساهمين سوف يتحملون
الامر الملفت انه تعوده الان الاسواق
الاسهم الامريكيه لان تسجل بعض الارتفاع
الداود جونز اصبح الان مرتفع ب 0.1%
والناس ايضا يسجل بعض الارتفاعات ماجد في
سؤال جدا مهم هل نحن عم نتحدث هنا انه
المشكله هي من اصول امنه يعني المشكله
الخسائل اللي بنيت بها هذه البنوك لانه
اضطرت لبيع اصول بخسائر ولكن هذه الاصول
هي سندات خزينه يلي بتحملها كل البنوك هي
من المفترض ان تكون اصول امنه جدا وليس
مثل الاصول يلي كانت حملتها البنوك ايام
الازمه الماليه العالميه هناك مخاوف
بالتالي انه بنوك اخرى تعاني من نفس
المشكله سؤال هنا هل يجب ان نتخوف من
البنوك انه البنوك في المنطقه ان تعاني
بنفس المشكله ام الوضع مختلف لانه مصادر
التمويل لدى هذه البنوك هي مختلفه ايضا
القوانين
والسيوله
والكابيتال اديك وسي لدى هذه البنوك ايضا
مختلفه عن البنوك الاصغر والقوانين يلي
بتحكم البنوك الاصغر في الولايات المتحده
اكيد طبعا يعني كمان احنا يعني شاهدنا
تراجعات اليوم باسواقنا واسواق السعوديه
على البنوك بشكل واضح على الرغم
الارتفاعات بدات فيها الاسواق يعني الوضع
مثل ما ذكرنا مختلف ومثل ما ذكرنا حضرتك
الوضع الاقتصادي والوضع المالي للبنوك
المحليه والبنوك السعوديه تختلف تماما عن
ما عم نشهدهم
باللي عم يصير ببنك معين بمنطقه معينه
بامريكا
ويعني مثل ما ذكرتي في فرق كبير بين
البنوك الكبيره اللي هي مثل
امريكا والى اخره البنوك الصغيره اللي هي
البنوك المحليه التي يعني تمول شريحه
معينه من من
في مجال مختص مثلا
هاي هاي موضوع والموضوع الاهم يعني مع
يعني هي الاسواق عاده يعني
على الاقتصاد الامريكي ولكن الاسواق بدات
بعمليه تسعير عدم رفع اسعار الفائده مره
اخرى هذه السنه يعني او على الاقل في في
في الاجتماع الفيدرالي القادم في اجتماع
الفيدرالي في الاسبوع القادم يعني انا
برايي انه هو شوي سابق لاوانه ولكن هو
احتمال اصبح حقيقي وموجود بالاسواق وهذا
يعني من اليوم احنا نشهد ارتفاعات ممكن
انه يسجل الناس ارتفاعات ويسجل مؤشر ستان
يعني تكونتهم واحد تكونته اله علاقه
بالتكنولوجيا وتستفيد من عدم رفع اسعار
الفائده والثاني البنوك الى وزن ثقيل على
مؤشر ستان ممكن انه يخلي المؤشر يتراجع
ونشوف هذا الفارق اليوم بالاداء بين
مؤشرين بيعطيك حس بانه الماركت او الاسواق
يعني ما زالت شغلها الاهم هو اسعار
الفائده والفدرالي ولكن هاي الحادثه يعني
لها تاثير على قطعه معين وليس الى تاثير
على باقي الاسواق وباقي المناطق في العالم
وحتى السوق الامريكي ولكن في قطاعات
مختلفه فالتاثير محدود
بقطوط بالبنوك الصغيره عندها انتشافات
وطبعا ظهر عده تقارير توضح البنوك لعند
انتشافات على هذه النوع من المحافظه على
كل بعض البنوك الاستثماريه مثل جولد من
سعر سلا بحسبوا انه ما في رفع للفائده
باجتماع مارس للفدرالي شكرا لك مجد دوله
مدير استثمارات الاسهم في بنك ابوظبي
الاول اذا ميسون كما تلاحظين بدانا هذه
النشره على تراجعات كانت فوق الواحد
بالمئه للاسهم الامريكيه الان نتحدث انه
الاسهم الامريكيه تعود لتسجل ارتفاعات في
تطمينات من خلال ما سمعته من اللقاء الان
ولكن النقطه الاساسيه اللي بدي اسالها هي
اذا لم يكن هناك تاثير مادي التاثير
النفسي هل يمكن على المدى البعيد ان يؤثر
ان كان على الاسواق او علينا بالمنطقه هلا
ميسون هي القصه انه يجب ان نفهم هنا هل
هذه حاله فرديه لعدد من البنوك ام نفس
المشكله ممكن ان نراها ببنوك اخرى لانه
كما تحدثنا هذه الاصول هي اصول محموله على
كل دفاتر البنوك يعني الب مفروض من اامن
اصل تحمله هي سندات خزينه صادره عن
حكوماتها بالتالي هي موجوده المشكله صارت
انه هل سندات راجعت اسهما لانه اسعار
الفائده ارتفعت وقت البنوك ما بتحمل
هالسندات لحين تاريخ استحقاقها
قبل تاريخ استحقاقها لانه عندها ازمه
بمعنى لانه عندها ازمه لانه في في اشخاص
عم بيروحوا يسحبوا ودائعهم بشكل سريع اضطر
مثل ما صار بهذا المصرف
على خسائر وقت يكون ما في مانجمنت اداره
صحيحه
لدوريشنز لاستحقاقات الودائع لدى المصرف
مقابل استحقاقات القرود ومدتها ها هي
الاداره يلي كنا شفناها هيدا ادى الى ازمه
بالتالي هي التي ستحاسب هاي اللي عم بحكي
عنها التي تحاسب هون السؤال السؤال هل
المشكله ببنوك معينه ام المشكله بالقطاع
المصرفي ممكن ان نرى تداعياتها بالقطاع
المصرفي كل ما نسمعه حتى الان من السلطات
مثلا الاوروبيه من المحللين عم بيقولوا ان
البنوك الاوروبيه تبعتها مختلفه وحتى
البنوك الامريكيه الكبرى بالتالي نعم فيها
لعب بالاسواق في نفسيه متداولين عم بتفاقم
الازمه كرده فعل بالاسواق ولكن عم نشوف
وربما ربما يعني عم نشوف هذا الهلع لانه
بالاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي اتخذتها
الحكومه الامريكيه انه كل الوداع سوف تكون
مؤمنه وليس فقط الودائع يلي اصلا عليها
تامين اللي هي 250 الف دولار والى مادوب
بريطانيا عملت نفس الشيء ولكن يقال انه
المساهمين هم من سيكون
مؤمنه ولكن
الخاسر الاكبر هو المساهم صحيح يلي ما انت
وقتها اصحاب البنوك اللي حطوا مصرياتهم في
الدائنين وفي الودائع الودائع كمان تحسب
تحتسب مثل الديون المصرف لانه هو مش اموال
للمصرف اعطوا اولويه انه المودعين هم اللي
بياخذوا الاموال عندما تصفيه اصول هذه
المصارف هن الاولويه لهم ولكن لن تعادل
اموال الى الدائنين الاخرين ولن تعود
الاموال الى اصحاب البنوك راح يتحملوا
الخسائر وهنا ايضا الامر الملفت انه هذه
الاموال سوف تعاد ولكن لن يضطر دافع
الضريبه الامريكي هو انه يا محمد هذه
الخسائر عم يحكوا من من العوائد الاتيه من
فانزيا فانز تامين صناديق تامين هي التي
سوف تعيد هذه الاموال بالاضافه الى الاصول
ما البنك لديه اصول رح يتم تصفيتها وسوف
تعادل اموال وايضا البنك رح يقدر ياخذ
قروض من الجهات التنطينيه مقابل هذه
القروض رح يعطي ضماناته الاصول بالتالي
كيف عامله هون كيف حاله الازمه جيده ولكن
لن يضطر ليبيع الان راح يعطيها للبنك
المركزي الامريكي وياخد مقابيله اموال
بالتالي بهذا بهذه الطريقه حمو نوعا ما
اصول المصرف اعطوه قرود مددوه اعطوه قرود
مقابل ضمانات بهذه الاصول وبهاال يجب ان
يعيد اموال المذيعين كل المذيعين بغض
النظر عن قيمه الاموال اذا كان في امكانيه
للاجابه مثل هذا القرار ببريطانيا قالوا
ان الحكومه سهلت وسرعت في عمليه استحواذ
وبالتالي النقطه الاساسيه ارادت ان تتخذ
ان يتخذ قرار اقتصادي جيد او تحمي نفسها
من ازمه جديده تزيد عليها الازمات
يعني اكيد يعني كان في ترحيب بالخطوات
السريعه التي اتخذت للحد من انتشار هذه
الاسماء وتخيل الميسون انه رغم هذه
الخطوات السريعه يلي اخذت قبل افتتاح
الاسواق اليوم شفنا هذه التراجعات رغم
التطمينات الاساسيه مبالك لو ما اخذوا مثل
هذه الاجراءات كم بنك اخر كان ممكن ان
يتعثر ان كنا نتحدث في الولايات المتحده
او في دول اخرى لانه قد ما كان حجم الباك
اذا صار في هلا لسحب الاموال ولا بنك
بيكون عنده كل الاموال المذيعين بيقدروا
يوفرها بفتره قصيره جدا شكرا نورت الخامسه
شكرا
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا تحدثت صحيفه
نقلا طبعا عن مصادر مقربه من الرئيس
الصيني شي جينج عن انه سيجتمع بالرئيس
الاوكراني بلا دمار عبر تقنيه الفيديو
وذلك لاول مره منذ الحرب في اوكرانيا
الصحيفه اشارت الى ان اللقاء سيكون عقب
زياره
كما قالت انه من المرجح ان يكون للرئيس
الصيني الزيارات لدول اوروبيه اخرى بعد
زياره موسكو
وفي هذه الاثناء ومع اتهامات غربيه لهما
بلعب دور في الحرب باوكرانيا التقى الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي مع نظيره
البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكيشنكو في طهران
رئيسي ولوكاشينكو اكادا رغبتهما في تعزيز
العلاقات بيننا البلدين على خلفيه الحرب
في اوكرانيا من جانبه شدد لوكاشينكو على
امكانيه الاستفاده المتبادله بين البلدين
اذا وحدت الجهود مشيرا في هذا السياق الى
تقنيات الحديثه والطاقه النوويه التي
تطورها طهران
اكدت الرئاسه الروسيه لكرملين ان الاهداف
التي وضعتها روسيا في اوكرانيا لا يمكن
تحقيقها حاليا الا بالوسائل العسكريه
المتحدث باسم الكريم
قال ان الاولويه المطلقه تضل دائما في
تحقيق اهداف روسيا في اوكرانيا مشيرا الى
انه في الوقت الراهن لا يمكن تحقيقها الا
بالعمل العسكري لم يستبعد بسكوب مشاركه
الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في قمه العشرين بالهند
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
تراكموا الاف الاطنان من القمامه في شوارع
باريس بسبب اضراب عمال النظافه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نكمل من ايران
حيث اعلن رئيس السلطه القضائيه الايرانيه
غلام حسين محسني الافراج عن 22 الف شخص
اعتقلي في الاحتجاجات الاخيره المناهضه
للحكومه الايرانيه في وقت ترجعت فيه حده
المظاهرات كان المرشد الايراني اصدر اول
قرارات العفو في فبراير الماضي شملت عدد
كبير من السجناء بعضهم اعتقلوا في اثناء
الاحتجاجات الاخيره
هذا وفيران ايضا ورغم نفي امريكي للتوصل
لصفقه بين واشنطن وطهران حول تبادل
السجناء المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه الناصر كنعاني اكد ان الجانب
الامريكي قبل باتمام تبادل السجناء في
احدى المراحل بعيدا طبعا عن المحادثات
الخاصه بالاتفاق النووي كنعاني شدد على
ضروره التعامل مع ملف تبادل السجناء
بواقعيه على عرض حد تعبيره مشيرا الى ان
طهران تؤمن بضروره الحصول على الضمانات
بشان التزام الجانب الامريكي
والان مشاهدينا من ايران الى افغانستان
حيث باتت الشواهد كثيره على ان الاقسام
بين قاده الطالبان في اتساع التقارير تشير
الى انه هناك تحركات جديده لتجديد قبضه
زعيم طالبان هبه الله اخ زاده على الحكومه
والامن وذلك بالاطاحه برئيس الاستخبارات
عبد الحق وثيق وتعيين احد قاده قندهار
طبعا المقربين منه ولكن يبدو ان تحركات اخ
زاده تلقى معارضه من جناح وزير الداخليه
سراج الدين حقاني والذي يتمسك ببقاء عبد
الحق وثيق في منصبه حيث ينظر لهذه الخطوه
على انها سعي لاضعاف موقف حقاني والذي بات
يشكل تهديدا خطيرا طبعا لسلطه قاده قندهار
مع تنامي نفوذه بالحركه ولكن لماذا يريد
حقاني الابقاء على رئيس الاستخبارات في
منصبه يرى مراقبون ان وثيق والذي ينتمي
ولايه جوزني جنوبيه غرب افغانستان يرى
حقاني محايدا في مواقفه بينه وبين قاده
جناح قندهار لاسيما وان انشقاقات باتت
واقعه في سلطه لبان بين جناح حقاني وخنت
زاده خصوصا مع سعي وزير الداخليه الى
تشكيل ما يشبه مجلس شورى للحكم كي لا تتخذ
القرارات داخل الحركه بشكل احادي وقد
استطاع بالفعل حقان استماله وزير الدفاع
محمد يعقوب نجم المؤسس الحركه ملا عمر
واقناعه بالتشاور مع القاده من اجل العمل
وبشكل جدي على تشكيل هذا المجلس حقاني كان
وجه الشهر الماضي انتقادات نادره لاخونت
زاده بسبب القرارات الاخيره
والمتعلقه بالقيود المفروضه على النساء
على كل معنى الان من الرياض الصحه في
الافغاني احمد السيد اهلا بك سيد احمد
اسمح لي ان ابدا بقراءتك من خلال متابعتك
عن التطورات ان كنا نتحدث عن ازمات هنا
وهناك داخل القياده بصوره عامه او لا نحن
نتحدث عن انشقاق وشرق حقيقي ربما بدا يظهر
الان الى العلم
في البدايه هو فعلا انشقاق او ليست
انشقاقات هي انقسامات داخل الحركه
انقسامات في المواقف في الافكار في الرؤى
في طريقه اداره البلاد مع الحركه
الطالبان يعني بالتالي هذه القرارات التي
يريد اصدارها زعيم طالبان هو يريدن
يسيطر على مفاصل الدوله بشكل كامل حتى على
الحكومه على المناصب الامنيه خصوصا وكذلك
المناصب السياديه
فمن ذلك الاساس يريد ان
يجعل الاشخاص المقربين منهم من قندهار في
المناصب الحساسه مثلا كرياسه الاستخبارات
وهي الاسهل طريقه له للسيطره على بعض
الاجهزه الامنيه بحكم الداخليه سيد احمد
لماذا نتحدث عن الجانب الامني عن
الاستخبارات تحديدا
لانه هو يرى خطر زعيم طالبان يرى الخطر
الذي يوجه اليه من ثلاثه اشخاص الان في
طالبان يرى الخطر هو من قاده الاجهزه
الامنيه الثلاثه وهم سراج الدين حقاني
وزير الداخليه والملا يعقوب نجل مؤسسه
الحركه وهو وزير الدفاع الحالي وهو من
قندهار ومع ذلك يعارض زعيم طالبان والشخص
الثالث هو وثيق رئيس الاستخبارات هو قاده
الاجهزه الامنيه لا يطلع زعيم طالبان على
كافه الامور والملفات الامنيه في طالبان
في الخصوصا قضايا الاستخبارات هو يريد باي
طريقه ما ان يصل الى الاجهزه الامنيه
الثلاثه يحاول تقييد سلطاتهم ولكن يصعب
عليه لذلك الافضل له ان يتوجه الى وثيق
ولطاح به ولكن
في ذلك سيد احمد وان لم ينجح هل نحن بصدد
مواجهه وكيف شكلها
حتى الان هو لم ينجح حتى الان يعني ما
زالت شبكه حقانيا الدين حقاني ما زال يرفض
اي شيء بالمساس بعبد الحق وثيق لانه يرونه
بانه ناجح في ادارته للاستخبارات رونا
ناجح خصوصا في حرب ضد داعش والقبض على بعض
قائدات قاده داعش كرسانا وحتى انه قتل
بعضهم وحتى الاجانب المتواجدين في
افغانستان المنتمين الى داعش ولذلك حقاني
لا يريد ان يغادر
وثيق الصديق المقرب منه هو الرجل المحايد
داخل الحركه بين الاجنحه الكبيره لانه لا
ينتمي الى قندهار ولا ينتمي الى حقاني وهو
في المنتصف لذلك ان يذهب شخص محايد وياتي
شخص من قندهار فهذه الامور اتوقع انها
تسبب ضعف لموقف حقاني كما ذكرتم ولكن هل
اذا لم ينجح يستطيع نتحدث عن حرب لا اتوقع
او قتال داخلي لا اتوقع حتى الان
ما زال حقاني
وغيرهم تحلون بالصبر من الرياضه الصحفي
الافغاني احمد السيد شكرا جزيلا لك
في خطوه اعتبرت لمواجهه زياده النفوذ
الصيني في المحيطين الهندي والهادي يعقد
قاده الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وايضا
استراليا اجتماع اليوم لوضع اللمسات
الاخيره على صفقه الغواصات النوويه التي
تنوي كمبيرا الحصول عليها ضمن طبعا
التحالف الامني المعروف باسم اوكس الصفحه
اثارت السيابيكين والتي سرعان ما نددت بما
اسمته بالتحركات غير المسبوقه طبعا لتكثيف
سباق التسلح النووي بحسب الصين هذا ويلتقي
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سونات طبعا بالاضافه الى
رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي انتني في قاعده
ساندييغو بولايه كاليفورنيا حيث تهدف
الدول الثلاث عبر هذه الاتفاقيه لتبادل
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه فضلا عن تزويد
استراليا بصواريخ توماهوك كروز كما تامل
الدول الثلاثه التعاون في مجال الصواريخ
الفرد صوتيه الذكاء الاصطناعي والحرب
الالكترونيه اعربت الصين عن معارضتها
الشديده لهذا التحالف حيث اعتبرت انه يهدف
الى محاصرتها في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادي ياتي ذلك وسط مخاوف من ان تتحول
التوترات لمواجهه عسكريه مباشره لا سيما
وان بكين زادت من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه
بنسبه اكثر من 7% لهذا العام هي طبعا
تعتبر اكبر زياده منذ عام 2019 طبعا هو من
جانبه وفي اول خطاب له منذ تنصيبه لولايه
ثالثه تعهد الرئيس الصيني
بتطوير الجيش الصيني وبجعله سوارا فولاديا
عظيما يحمي مصالح الصين وامنها بشكل فعال
نتابع
الامن هو اساس التنميه والاستقرار هو
الشرط الاساسي للازدهار وعلينا تنفيذ نهج
شامل للامن القومي وتحسين نظام الامن
القومي لدينا وتعزيز قدرتنا على حمايه
الامن القومي وتعزيز اداره السلامه العامه
وكذلك تحسين نظام الحوكمه الاجتماعيه
لضمان نموذج انمائي جديد
يجب علينا المضي قدما في حملتنا للتعبئه
فيما يتعلق بالدفاع الوطني والجيش
وتحويل جيش الصين الى جدار كبير من الصلب
المزيد معنا مبركين الصحفي نادر رونج اهلا
بك سيد نادر بدايه من خلال متابعتك كيف
يمكن ان نصف الوضع الان والعلاقات ما بين
الدول والرسائل المرسله من جهه كمبيرا
والغواصه ومن جهه اخرى الصين وطبعا الجيش
الفولادي بحسب الرئيس الصيني
اهلا ومرحبا بكم طبعا هذا الخطوه لتزويد
يعني
الدوله ومنطقه خاليه من الاسلحه النوويه
وهذا خطوه خطيره جدا
سيؤدي الى الجوله الجديده من السباق
والتسلح في هذه المنطقه وكذلك هذا ايضا
يخرب النظام الدولي لعدم انتشار النووي
وكذلك يعني يخرب معاهده الدوليه لاعدم
انتشار نووي فكل هذه يعني سيؤدي المنطقه
الى المجابهه بين كتله باي اطار بس قضيه
التسارع نحو
تطوير الجانب النووي او انه لا في مواجهه
مباشره يعني ردع او
مواجهه سيد نادر
اعتقد سيكون هناك يعني تسعيد في يعني
السباق التسامحه
لزياده خطوره المواجهه بين مختلف الدول
وكذلك هذا ايضا يعني يخالف تطلعات الدول
المنطقه والشعوب المنطقه
للحفاظ على منطقه يعني خاليه من الاسلحه
النوويه
وكان هناك ايضا معارضه من
نيوزيلندا وغيرها من الدول الجزر على
منطقه الجنوب المحيط الحادي
يجب خلينا يعني في تصعيد تقول وان الامور
لا تتجه الى ناحيه ربما فيها نوع من
التهدئه
وبالتالي السؤال الان كيف ستتعامل الصين
مع هذه التطورات وهل في امكانيه خاصه انه
كان قبل الحديث عن المنطاد كان في حديث عن
زياره لمسؤول امريكي الى الصين هل يمكن ان
تعود هذه الزياره على السطح الان قريبا
ويكون هناك حوار بين الولايات المتحده
والصين او لا الموضوع خرج عن السيطره الان
هذا يعني يتوقف على سلوك الولايات المتحده
طبعا وهنا الصين تحافظ يعني على يعني
قنوات اتصال المفتوحه مع الولايات المتحده
على جميع المستويات
والصين يعني تريد يمكن ان نرى يعني
الاجتماع الثلاثي نفس الاجتماع الثلاثي في
باكين قبل ايام ويشتمل معه ثلاثي في
الولايات المتحده الصين ويريد السلام
وتعميم السلام في العالم وفي منطقه الشرق
الاوسط هناك
المصالحه بين
السعوديه وايران بالجهود وساطه الصينيه
ولكن ما تفعل الولايات المتحده هو من اجل
تشكيل تحالفات وزياده التواتر والمجابهه
وهذا يعني هو تعاكس
يعني فلسفه مختلفه كذلك
لا تريد اي مواجهه في
المنطقه والزياده النمو العسكريه هو زياده
القوه الداعمه للسلام في العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك
تكدست اكوام القمامه في احياء وشوارع
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس مع استمرار حركه
الاضرابات والاحتجاجات المناهضه لمشروع
قانون رفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عام
فيما تخطط النقابات لتنظيم المزيد من
المسيرات والاحتجاجات حتى تراجع الحكومه
وتتراجع عن هذه الخطه
[موسيقى]
الوضع ليس احسن حالا في المانيا حيث
استمرت الاضرابات حول اجور العمال ما ادى
الى شل حركه الطيران في مطارات عده في
برلين هامبرج هانوفر حيث الغيت حوالي 200
رحله سيتم ايضا الغاء ثلث الرحلات القادمه
رفقه شارك الاف الاطباء المبتدئين في
اضراب لمده ثلاثه ايام تمديدا بعدم تعديل
مرتباتهم ويعد طبعا هذا الاضراب احدث
سلسله من الاضرابات في قطاعات خدمه عده
سعيا طبعا لزياده الاجور
[تصفيق]
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
فيلم
يحصد اهم جوائز الاوسكار السينمائيه
بنسختها 95 فيها
اهلا بكم مجددا افادت لجنه معينه من الامم
المتحده للتحقيق بشان سوريا بان كلا من
المنظمه الدوليه والنظام السوري وبعض ايضا
الجهات تتحمل مسؤوليه التاخير في ايصال
المساعدات الى السوريين بعد زلزال حيث
شددت اللجنه على ضروره ان تقوم جميع
الاطراف السوريه بتسليم الاغاثه الانسانيه
بحياديه وبدون عوائق مشيره الى ان طريقه
معامله الاف المحتجزين في مخيمات بسوريا
ترقى لجريمه حرب ياتي هذا وسط انتقادات
متزايده تتعرض لها المنظمه لدورها في
المرحله التي اعقبت مباشره عقبات الزلزال
الذي وقع الشهر هذا
[موسيقى]
الى تونس الان حيث عقد البرلمان اولى
جلساته اليوم بعد انقطاع دام اكثر من سنه
ونصف اسره تجميد اعمال المجلس التشريعي
طبعا بقرار من الرئيس قيس سعيد تراس
الجلسه الافتتاحيه اكبر النواب سنا النائب
صالح المباركي ساعده اصغر نائبين وهما
غسان يامون وسيرين بوصندل وقد اكد صالح
المباركي في كلمه افتتاحيه انه من
الواجبات المطروحه على النواب العمل ضمن
اطار تشاركي وتجاوب مع السلطه التنفيذيه
وفق ما يفرضه الواجب الوطني مؤكدا ان جلسه
اليوم لحظه فارقه في تاريخ البلاد
بدات اكبر مناورات عسكريه بين الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه منذ خمس سنوات
الجيشان قال ان التدريبات ستعزز الموقف
الدفاعي المشترك وستشمل تدريبات ميدانيه
بما في ذلك عمليات الانزال البرمائي قبل
ذلك سبقت كوريا الشماليه هذه المناورات
باطلاق صاروخين استراتيجيين من طراز كروز
من على متنقه غواصه وافادت وكاله الانباء
الكوريه الشماليه ان عمليه اطلاق
الصاروخين تمت قباله سواحل مدينه سيمبو في
شرق البلاد
في هذه الاثناء قال كبير امناء مجلس
الوزراء الياباني ان طوكيو ستبقى متيقظه
بعد اطلاق كوريا الشماليه للصاروخين وذلك
احتجاج طبعا على المناورات العسكريه
المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الشماليه كما ذكرنا نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الساعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الجميله فعلا فرحت الفوز كبيره جدا نصل
الى نهايه الخامسه لمتابعه ملفات العربيه
المزيد ايضا من الاخبار والتحليلات على
موقعنا العربيه الرجاء مسح الكود الظاهر
على الشاشه شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]